dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Olathe here today we
are going to discuss a great piece of
work that shows us how efficient and
versatile neural network based
techniques have become recently here the
input is a bunch of RGB d images which
are photographs endowed with depth
information and the output can be a full
3d reconstruction of the scene and much
much more which we'll see in a moment
this task is typically taken care of by
handcrafting descriptors a descriptor is
a specialized representation for doing
useful tasks on images and other data
structures for instance if we seek to
build an algorithm to recognize black
and white images the useful descriptor
would definitely contain the number of
colors that are visible in an image and
the list of these colors again these
descriptors have been typically
handcrafted by scientists for decades
new problem new descriptors new papers
but not this time because here
super-effective descriptors are proposed
automatically via a learning algorithm a
convolutional neural network and Tsai
amis networks this is incredible
creating such descriptors took extremely
smart researchers and years of work on a
specific problem and were still often
not as good as these ones by the way we
have discussed Tsai amis networks in an
earlier episode as always the link is
available in the video description and
as you can imagine several really cool
applications emerge from this one when
combined with ransack a technique used
to find order in noisy measurement data
it is able to perform 3d scene
reconstruction from just a few images
and it completely smokes the competition
to post estimation with bounding boxes
given a sample of an object the
algorithm is able to recognize not only
the shape itself but also its
orientation when given a scene cluttered
with other objects
three correspondent search is possible
this is really cool this means that a
semantically similar piece of geometry
is recognized on different objects for
instance the algorithm can learn the
concept of the handle and recognize the
handles on a variety of objects such as
on motorcycles carriages chairs and more
the source code of this project is also
available Yahoo neural networks are
rapidly establishing supremacy in a
number of research fields and I am so
happy to be alive in this age of
incredible research progress make sure
to subscribe to the series and click the
bell icon some amazing works are coming
up in the next few episodes and there
will be lots of fun to be had thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you